on vous parle du froid du froid mordant
depuis le tout début de l'émission
ce matin mais pourquoi parce qu'on est
tout proche d'un record
on va attendre de voir ce qu'un
environnement canada avant dire mais ça
ferait plus de 50 ans qu'on n'a pas vu
ça montréal - 11 moins 12 degrés pour la
mi-novembre
si l'hiver bien avant son temps matthew
pearce qui est directeur général de la
mission aubry en sait quelque chose mais
c'est plus bonjour au moteur comment ça
s'est passé pour vous là pour les sans
abri à montréal ses nuits cette nuit
c'était une autre nuit de d'achalandage
tous les lys ont été prises et il y
avait même des gens qui ont dû dormir
dans la cafétéria qui n'est pas l'idéal
c'est pas humaine je dirais c'est pas
digne mais j'ai mieux que dormir dehors
veut dépasser largement la capacité
présentement en effet en effet il y à
certaines refuge à montréal qui
lorsqu'il s'affiche complète vont
refuser l'accès nous on accepte toutes
les personnes c'est juste qu'on on va
devoir d héberger dans un contexte moins
que l'idéal
quitte à dormir dans la cafétéria mais
au moins au chaud est ce qu'à ce moment
là vous avez quand même des matelas des
couvertures ou c'est directement sur une
lancée dans une chaise peut-être sur la
table
c'est donc mais comme je dis c'est mieux
que d'être d'or dans un grand froid
comme on vit maintenant ça c'est sûr et
comment comment est ce qu'on explique
quand même là on le voyait venir ce
froid là depuis quelques jours on n'est
pas capable de se revirer de bord comme
on dit le de s'organiser rapidement pour
que les autres fusillades de chaleur de
la ville de montréal sera ouverte dès
les halles de chaleur vont ouvrir ils
vont ouvrir le 2 décembre et tout est
planifié autour de ça on a un protocole
c'est tout et coordonnée on peut pas
juste dire tout de suite ça ouvre je
sais que c'est peut-être surprenant
pauvres pour vous et pour le public mais
en fait c'est difficile de dieu sur le
champ ouvrir quelque chose il y avait
une complexité personnel embauché
je comprends en même temps quand arrive
une catastrophe quand il ya des
inondations
on est capable d'ouvrir des centres
d'urgence pendant la nuit alors qu'on ne
savait pas du tout que ça allait se
produire on est capable de le faire
on est capable et notre notre façon de
faire ce que vous proposez c'est
d'ouvrir la cafétéria alors c'est
disponibles aux personnes qu'il y aura
une unité de débordements qui va ouvrir
avec 150 lits le 2 décembre il y aura
les achats leurs dons dans une semaine
mais je crois qu'on va être correct
entre temps on va vivre avec une hiver
précoce qui nous on nous a pris par
surprise mais je comprends et en même
temps la complexité mais ce que vous
demandez aussi à la ville de montréal de
capable d'ouvrir de façon plus précoce
ou pour vous c'est ça qu'on vient quand
même là et ça me convient pas non
j'aimerais mieux qu'on puisse être agir
plus rapidement et ouvrir cesser ces
lieux là plutôt quand il ya un moment
comme ceux ci qui exige une réponse
appropriée
alors oui je fais vrai cela il faut
miser toutefois sur pas uniquement le
situations d'urgence des gens si on peut
d engranger les équipes
les refuges par un accès au logement
abordable pour ces personnes là
peut-être à l'avenir on n'aurait pas
recours
ces unités de débordement et
l'achalandage et la cafétéria et tout et
j'imagine que des réflexions aussi qui
sont pour que l'on soit prêt à tout
moment de l'année parce qu'on sait que
l'hiver peut commencer plus tôt
finalement un peu finir plus tard faut
pas non plus arrêter une date dans le
calendrier
en effet sans abri n'ont pas de maison à
l'année en effet en effet on sait jamais
quand est-ce que ça va arriver le grand
divers et les grands froids donc il faut
que nous soyons je crois plus prête que
nous y étions cette année dans la
journée comment ça va se passer vous
offrez aussi des repas chauds oui oui
oui tous les repas chauds et la mission
au bruit en comparaison des autres
refuges ne ferme pas durant deux jours
les gens peuvent rester la journée
longue à l'intérieur et nous avons un
café internet où les gens peuvent avoir
un café et être au à l'abri du grand
froid de la journée l'on est ce que vous
êtes capable de passer une prochaine
nuit parce que la nuit prochaine
s'annonce sensiblement aussi froide
êtes vous capable de faire la même chose
ou vous réclamer des mesures d'urgence
par exemple est la vie je crois que nous
allons poursuivre les mesures déjà en
place et la cafétéria votre disposition
de autant de gens qui en veulent et qui
ont en ont besoin et on va planifier
pour l'ouverture des attaches à l'heure
et le min tit de débordement de décembre
savez-vous en terminant à ce qu'il ya
des navettes qui font tourner des
secteurs pour s'assurer que la personne
qui dort c'est donc que vous demandez ça
puisque c'est la mission qui en perdent
là n'avait alors d'annabelle oui ça
circule actuellement et depuis plusieurs
mois et ça circule dans les rues de
montréal où se situe parfois des gens
qui pour une raison les auteurs ont pas
cherché à être à naître ne meure
on les accueille de la navette et on les
amène chine oui sans savoir où aller
comme ça vous allez les chercher et on
va déposer un endroit où il ya de la
place excellent m'a surpris hier merci
beaucoup merci david nouveau ce matin